the thing that i sometimes worry about
is
uh the fact that we haven't seen
overwhelming evidence of alien
civilizations out there
makes me think um well there's a lot of
explanations but one of them that
worries me is that
whenever they get smart they just
destroy themselves oh yeah
i mean that was the most fascinating is
the most fascinating and chilling
number or variable in the drake equation
is l at the end
and at the end of it you look out and
you see you know
one to 400 billion stars in the milky
way galaxy
and we now know because of kepler that
an astonishingly high percentage of them
probably have habitable planets
and you know so all the things that were
unknowns when the drake equation was
originally written
like you know how many stars have
planets actually back then in the 1960s
when the drake equation came along
the consensus amongst astronomers was
that it would be a small minority of
solar systems that had planets or
stars but now we know it's substantially
all of them how many of those stars have
habit
have planets in the habitable zone it's
kind of looking like 20
like oh my god and so l which is how
long does
a civilization once it reaches
technological competence
continues to last yeah that's the doozy
and and you're right it's it's
all too plausible to think that when a
civilization reaches a level of
sophistication that's probably just a
decade or three in our future
the odds of it self-destructing just
start mounting astronomically no pun
intended
my hope is that that uh actually there
is a lot of alien civilizations out
there and what they figure out in order
to avoid
the self-destruction they need to turn
off the
thing that was useful that used to be a
feature now became a bug which is uh
the desire to colonize to conquer more
land to so they
like there's probably ultra intelligent
alien civilizations out there they're
just like chilling
like on the beach with the with the
whatever your favorite alcohol belt
beverages but like without sort of
trying to conquer
everything just chilling out and maybe
exploring in the in the realm of
knowledge but almost like
appreciating existence for its own sake
versus uh life as a
progression of conquering of other life
like this kind of predator prey
formulation that
resulted in us humans perhaps is
something we have to shed in order to
survive i don't know
yeah that that is um a very plausible
solution to fermi's paradox and it's
it's one that makes sense
you know when we look at our own lives
and their own archive project
of technological um you know trajectory
it's very very easy to imagine that in
an intermediate future world of
you know flawless vr or flawless you
know
whatever kind of simulation that we want
to inhabit
it will just simply cease to be
worthwhile
to go out and and expand our
interstellar territory and but if we
were
going out and conquering interstellar
territory wouldn't necessarily have to
be predator or prey i can imagine
um a benign but sophisticated
intelligence saying well we're going to
go to places we're going to go to places
that we can terraform
and use a different word than terra
obviously but we can turn into habitable
for our particular
physiology uh so long as that they don't
house
you know intelligent sentient creatures
that would suffer from our invasion
um but it is easy to see a sophisticated
intelligence species evolving to the
point where interstellar travel with its
incalculable expense and physical
hurdles just isn't worth it compared to
what could be done
you know where one already is
you